today on the Matt Walsh show years ago I
wrote that the United States of America
no longer exists and sadly I think
recent events have only proven my point
we are not united in this country and
that is not going to change anytime soon
so what is what does that mean and where
do we go from here
what's what's just the the reality of
the situation we're gonna talk about all
that today also five headlines including
you may have heard of those
insurrectionists who are taking over
parts of seattle well now they're trying
their hand at building a self-sustaining
commune but these are all a bunch of
city dwellers who have no survival
skills whatsoever so it's going about as
about as about as well as you might
imagine and later we're gonna play a new
game that I invented called
the cringe challenge it's a very
difficult game sort of a harrowing game
to play and the winner loses really but
we're gonna play that today all that's
coming up stick around for that
but first you know these days when it's
difficult to get together with the
people you love and and you know maybe
where you you haven't seen some of your
relatives in a while that's why it's
even more important I think what paint
your life offers is even more important
because you can feel like you're good
together even when you're not if you're
looking for a way to feel connected to
loved ones when you can't be near you've
got to try paint your life calm you get
a professional hand painted portrait
created from any photo at a truly
affordable price we've done this
ourselves we've got a great painting
from a photo of our kids it's hanging
proudly in our living room we really do
love it you know it is great I can't say
enough good things about it it's a very
user friendly platform it's a sort of a
hands-on process where you you obviously
picked the picture you want and
throughout the process you know you're
gonna give your feedback if you want
things to be changed they'll change it
they're very receptive to that and
responsive as well and in the end what
really matters is that this is a
professional real artist making this
painting for you and it's just beautiful
at paint your life calm there's no risk
if you don't love the final painting
your money is refunded guaranteed and
right now is a limited time offer get
20% off your painting that's right 20%
off and free shipping to get this
special offer text the word
Matt to 64,000 that's Matt to 64,000
texts Matt to 64,000 paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
alright so I want to have a conversation
something I mentioned on the show at
various points a few times in the recent
weeks but now I want to dig into this
and really talk about it in depth but to
do that I have to go back to something
that one of the first articles I wrote
actually for The Daily wire was a
typically optimistic and cheerful piece
titled the the United States of America
no longer exists and at the time it was
not met with a very warm reception from
a lot of readers and I mean I kind of
understand that because number one I
just started at the site so I think a
lot of people they didn't know who I was
and who is this guy who is this guy
coming in here one of the first things
he tells us the United States doesn't
exist it was a tad bleak I admit three
years later it brings me no pleasure to
say I told you so usually one of my
favorite things to say my wife will tell
you but in this case not so much my
basic thesis in that piece was that our
country though existing still in as a
legal and geographic entity cannot be
meaningfully described as United so the
United States of America no longer
exists except in name we have nothing
but the law and the land holding us
together and that is not enough to make
a nation to make a people there needs to
be something else some uniting principle
some defining commonality that binds us
if we are going to be united we must be
united around something and buy
something today three years later all of
that holds true only more so the key
difference between now and three years
ago is that you know arguably we no
longer even have the law holding us
together between the unconstitutional
lockdowns and a sudden abandonment of
those of those policies in order to
allow rampaging mobs to wreak havoc in
the streets for weeks on end the rule of
law has broken down
and with our border still about as
porous as I've ever been you know it's
hard to say that we are meaningfully
united even on a geographic level so
with these two pillars crumbling pillars
that were already insufficient in
themselves to keep a country together
what's left is the question many nations
around the world and throughout history
have been held together by the bonds of
their common heritage ancestry language
tradition these are the kinds of things
that for many countries that's what
makes it a country now the United States
has always been different in in these
respects what we once did have a common
language and at least a few cultural
traditions that we all had in common now
though it's ethnocentric and xenophobic
and racist to expect immigrants who come
to this country to learn the language of
the country they're immigrating to as
for traditions our national holidays
like Thanksgiving and Columbus Day have
been abolished in many quarters and that
trend is rapidly gaining speed it's
either the trend is going in the
direction of it happening more not less
no doubt Memorial Day and Independence
Day will be on the chopping block soon
enough these holidays are being torn
down along with the statues of our
historical icons and politicize like
like the sporting events that once gave
us respite from the political
back-and-forth and now even those are
our platforms for the culture war our
political events almost these losses are
not insignificant to you to lose
holidays to lose the statues you know
that is not an insignificant thing
healthy vibrant countries have always
had their traditions have always had
their holidays have always had their
heroes we're gonna try to be the first
country in history without any of that I
don't think the experiment will prove
successful but the thing that has always
made America unique of course is that
it's a nation founded on ideas on
so you could say that hey we can survive
tear down the statues get rid of the
holidays that's not what makes America
America and I agree that's not what
makes America America if nothing else we
were once joined by our shared belief in
the ideas and the creed that lays of the
foundation of our country we have never
succeeded in actually applying all of
those lofty principles to everybody
equally you know that all men are
created equal endowed by the creator
with inherent dignity and value we have
never succeeded in actually applying
that to everybody
never and we don't now now we we exclude
the you know 1 million babies who are
killed every year so these are there
there have always been some some really
glaring and and and terrible exceptions
that we have made to that but we shared
these ideas on an aspirational level at
least now we no longer even aspire to be
that sort of country many Americans
fundamentally reject the inherent
dignity of human beings it's not just
that they believe in the inherent
dignity and they profess it but they
don't apply that principle to babies
that would be bad enough no it's it's
that for a lot of people they just don't
believe that that's the case they don't
think people have inherent dignity and
worth so we are no longer at least
aspiring to be the sort of country that
protects and values all people equally
and our ideas of what it means to be
equal are are so elementally opposed as
to render the term meaningless are we
join then by our shared desire to be
free is that is that something that we
can say at least I know maybe we'll have
anything else but it were America we
love freedom we've got that going at
least for us know in the minds of many
people the ultimate vision of freedom is
a socialist utopia where the free market
is abolished the Gov
provides all the basic needs michaleen
controlled and planned by the government
now to me and to many others this is a
vision of slavery this is not a vision
of freedom so it may be true that all
Americans talk about freedom that we all
say we want freedom but the only
commonality between the competing views
of freedom is the word itself nothing
else can we be bound by our passion for
human rights again know the situation
with rights is is much like that with
freedom those on the Left not just on
the on the leftist fringes but in the
mainstream would say that mothers have a
right to kill their offspring some
Americans have a right to the money and
property of other Americans biological
males have a right to enter a woman's
locker room or beyond her sports and gay
couples have a right to the goods and
services of Christian business owners
and so on they see a human right as
something always in competition with
other rights claims so for them rights
are a competition a struggle one right
must always supersede another right so
we've got this concept of superseding
rights the woman's right to autonomy
trounces violently a child's right to
life a college students right to be free
of debt overpowers a wealthy man's right
to the fruit of his own labor and so on
now I would say that what they're really
describing is one groups struggle for
power and dominance over another you
know this is nothing to do with rights
rights are inherent to our human nature
by definition human rights real human
rights cannot be in competition with one
another if you find yourself weighing
these claims to superseding rights and
trying to figure out who's right comes
before the you know the you know who's
right comes before the other if you find
yourself doing that it means that your
whole concept of Rights Human Rights is
flawed
that's the way
I would say and since we have
fundamentally opposing definitions of
the term Human Rights we cannot be
united around it if we cannot be united
around tradition around language around
heritage and we also cannot be united
around a shared belief in freedom and
human rights then what's left we would
appear already to be two different
countries or perhaps several different
countries and even that is generous
because really when it would a man when
I talk to somebody and he tells me that
he believes babies aren't people that
it's OK for a mother to kill her child
who we call it which he calls a fetus a
biological sex doesn't exist men can get
pregnant Police Department should be
abolished America's racist to its core
I'm a white supremacist if I disagree
with any of these points when I'm told
this I find myself questioning whether
we're even from the same planet let
alone the same from the same universe
let alone the same country this is how
absolutely opposed we are on all levels
with almost no common ground no shared
frame of reference and and that's why if
you're wondering why our arguments and
debates are so unproductive they never
go anywhere it's because we have no way
to argue these points we have no way to
communicate in order to communicate and
debate someone you have to have some
frame of reference that you share
between you two yeah there has to be
something there I mean there's these
some common value you both have and
that's gonna be your starting but you're
gonna build from that when you're having
your debate but if you don't even have
that there's just nothing that can
happen here it's not going to go
anywhere and that's where we are in our
country where we've got we've got people
there's just there's just nothing there
at all that they share and it is not
exactly exaggeration to say that in this
way we are far more divided now than we
were during the Civil War I mean you
read about the Civil War obviously we
can't romanticize or idealize the Civil
War 600,000 people died it was a brew
violent horrible horrific nightmarish
time so there's no doubt about that
but even then you know fundamentally the
two sides were not nearly as opposed you
know sort of philosophically as as as we
are now because they at least had you
know they had some common ideas like
common ideas like dignity and manliness
and honor you know they had they had
that between them at least I mean they
even both they even both was valued
freedom it's just that they had very
different ideas of what freedom meant
but they did and you know which is the
case now you could say but they did
believe that you know you had human
rights endowed by the creator inherent
human dignity they believed in that they
didn't apply it equally they didn't
apply it all the way there are obviously
some some some huge blind spots they're
just like we have now but it on an
aspirational level they they had they
had that there was something there there
was a there was a morsel of something
which is why you know the Civil War
ended reconstruction was a terrible time
as well in many ways but the country did
survive somehow 600,000 people died
brutal violent there was a worst war
we've ever seen still to this point in
America anyway the deadliest war it
survived and America went on to become a
powerhouse how'd that happen I think one
of the ways it happens is that there
there was at least some commonality some
shared uniting principles that they had
as opposed as they were on so many other
things we don't have that now what does
that mean well you know I guess this is
the part where I'm supposed to have a
solution you know I'm supposed to give
you the one two three step plan of how
we can solve all these problems and and
come together I don't have it that's
sort of my point I just think that we
need to begin by confronting and
acknowledging the situation we are
actually in as a country and
we need to be realistic and so if you're
sitting there calling for unity and
saying we need to put our differences
aside it's not gonna happen it can't
happen
in order for that to happen millions of
Americans on one side of the other are
going to have to radically change how
they see reality and that's not going to
happen overnight or at all potentially
so we just need to start thinking about
what we can actually do in light of all
of this you know the only problem people
talk about breaking apart as a country
and you know forming two different
countries I think there's a lot to be
said for that actually listen not it no
country lasts forever
no country does they all come to an end
we have to confront that reality - the
only problem is though that that our
division is not as geographically
defined as it was during say the Civil
War so I don't know how that would work
but I think we need to start thinking on
along the lines of what can we do in
light of the fact that there are these
unbridgeable gaps separating one group
of Americans from others all right we're
gonna move on to headlines in just a
second but before we do a word from
legacy box you know if you're if you're
looking for a way to get all your your
old family home movies pictures and
stuff like that you want to get it all
in one place you don't want to lose them
you don't them to get ruined
then legacy box is a way to do it's a
super simple mail and service to have
all your home movies and pictures
digitally preserved on a thumb drive DVD
or the cloud don't let those priceless
family memories disappear because that's
what happens if you don't take action
instead here's an idea whatever your
favorite memories are and let's say we
got Father's Day coming up whatever your
favorite memories are with Dad learning
to ride a bike camping fishing whatever
it is how about taking all of those
memories and putting it on legacy box
and giving it to dad for Father's Day
I'm telling you he'll love that legacy
box is a way for you to easily
affordably digitally preserve your path
the process again is is the word we keep
come back to it's easy as an easy
process from start to finish I've done
it myself and look if I can do it then
you can do it get started preserving
your family's legacy today go to legacy
box comm slash walls to get an
incredible 50 percent off your first
order but today to take advantage of
this exclusive offer sending when you're
ready legacy box is is great for you or
someone you love so if you buy today you
know you have to send in right away but
you're taking the Vantage of the offer
now while you can go to legacy box comm
slash Walsh and save 50% off while
supplies last okay headlines number one
and Tifa people in the so called
autonomous zone are making a stab at
self-reliance they've started a little
farming project take a look at the
picture here isn't that the saddest
thing you've ever seen and look at the
guy sitting there watching the plants
expecting like an entire large salad to
just sprout out of the ground all at
once but so they've got topsoil on top
of cardboard and that's that's where
they're starting it but then it looks
like they've got some of the plants that
that aren't actually planted they're
just sitting on the top of the soil
maybe that's what they think topsoil
means it stops little so you just put
the stuff right on top and then you see
in the back there if you got that little
watering can they're gonna try to keep
this whole plot watered with a little
plastic water again like the thing that
my daughter uses to water the garden
because she wants to feel like she's
helping and the problem is even if all
those crops come up which they won't
you've got enough food there to maybe
maybe feed three people in a couple of
months in late August there will be
enough food for you know three adults to
have a couple slices of tomato handful
lettuce a cucumber so this is pretty
pathetic you almost feel sorry for these
these city slickers playing play acting
as survivalist and and here's the thing
you know if if you're really serious
about this and you want to have your own
calm you in your own little community
and you want to be relatively free of
government interference and you really
just want to be on your own make your
own rules
I respect that actually I got nothing
but respect for that you want to drop
off the grid do your own thing say screw
you to modern society I love it I think
it's a great idea you can't do it in the
middle of Seattle okay that that's not
what you do if you're serious about it
go off into the wilderness there's a lot
of wilderness still still left in
America and you could go off into the
woods somewhere into the mountains into
the desert wherever you want to go and
take a stab at it
and if you do that you know for the most
part the government will leave you alone
with some rather notable and awful
exceptions if you were serious about it
but they're not serious about it this
again is just play-acting this is like a
theater performance on their part
they're not serious about actually
trying to create their own state or
community and and of course if they did
try to go into the woods and survive
they'd all be dead in three days so
maybe they shouldn't actually do that
but you know that's anyone anyone can
you can go and go give it a shot
all right number two big news from NBC
Eric whemple of The Washington Post
reports effective immediately NBC News
and MSNBC will capitalize the be in
black when referring to people or the
community across all the networks
platforms so black people capital OB why
I have no idea well we know why because
we've we've learned that proper grammar
is violence and so this is that's that's
not that's not proper grammar but this
is a struggle against many things
including grammar number three crazy
story out of Baltimore reported by Fox
45 according to a woman named Courtney
Lancaster in Baltimore County
her son was having his virtual class
recently he's a attends public school
elementary school and he was doing his
virtual class like so many kids are
across the country during the during
COBIT and someone notices on the wall
behind him in his home a BB gun which is
which is hanging there on the wall the
principal notifies the school resource
officer
he calls the cops and then the cops show
up at the woman's house and search her
house because of a BB gun and the
principal apparently according to mother
said that having a BB gun in your own
home during a virtual class is
tantamount to bringing it to school
because because now they own your house
right you send your kid to public school
they own your kid in their minds if you
do virtual school they still own your
kid and now they own your house too
because they can see it get your kids
out of public school system people get
them out number four the Dallas Police
Department put out a video yesterday
kneeling in submission to the black
lives matter organization here's a
little bit of that video
[Music]
take your heart for people of color get
over because the city because a minority
majority says is a city with blacks of
white and brown they going illegal
I'll get together because we judge each
other by the content of
[Applause]
pretty bold stuff there from from that
officer right hey if you're racist get
over it
I disagree I disagree with racism you
hear me
I'm not afraid to say it racism is bad
yeah then the crowd cheers no how about
this don't kneel don't kneel get it get
up get off of your knees and do your
damn jobs how's that for an idea enforce
the law you can't do it from your knees
get off your knees stop embarrassing
yourself and do your job
protect the community that's what people
want
that's what communities want at least
the people in the community who you
should be listening to want the law to
be enforced number 5 finally here's
Donald Trump talking about the takeover
in Seattle by the anarchists if there
were more toughness you wouldn't have
the kind of devastation that you had in
Minneapolis and in Seattle I mean let's
see what's going on and I will tell you
if they don't straighten that situation
out we're gonna straighten it out and
what do you mean by that
like what I don't know if you caught it
but Governor Cuomo was so upset with
mayor de Blasio of New York he said I'm
gonna displace him I don't really know
how that would work but I mean is that
what you mean in Seattle what I mean is
very simple we're not gonna let Seattle
be occupied by anarchists and I'm not
calling demitasse nesters I'm not cause
they know it but I got to see a
performance that I've never seen yeah I
mean you think he was a weak person in
Minneapolis the woman I don't know has
she ever done this before how can in
Seattle
oh it's pathetic I like what he says
there of course a lot of people on the
Left are upset as always every time he
opens his mouth they're upset but I like
what he says there sounds good to me
the only problem is is is is with Trump
oftentimes the problem is when it comes
to actually doing it so I like what
you're saying great stuff tweeting it
that's good stuff too trump's been
tweeting a lot of doing a lot of
tweeting during all this it keeps
tweeting law and order in all caps
he's tweeted that you know like 10 times
I agree law and order is good at a
certain point though you have to go
beyond tweeting and just saying it and
actually do something that that's that's
part of governing so he's got the tweet
down he's got all that down but it makes
it so much worse you know and I know
there's no point complaining about it
now I mean Trump is Trump isn't and not
it's not ever gonna change he's 74 years
old he's not gonna change and the
Twitter thing it's not ever gonna change
never will
yeah you know it'll go down I mean he'll
if he's going down he's gonna go down
tweeting even if tweeting takes him down
he's doesn't care he's gonna he's gonna
cling to that alright I get that all
right but even so the reality is that
when you've got riots and the breakdown
of law and order and the president isn't
really doing anything except just
tweeting the phrase law and order it
looks impotent and pitiful and weak and
that is not the image that Trump should
be projecting so what I would like is
for him to actually do something about
it actually fall through on some of
these threats for a change if you're not
though then probably stop tweeting law
and order because it you know it only it
only highlights the fact that there
isn't law and order right now and you're
not doing anything about it okay let's
go to our daily cancelation before we do
I want to tell you about our very good
friends over at rockauto.com it's this
is a no brainer if you can get the auto
parts from the website rather than going
into an auto parts store then you're
going to want to do that it's a literal
little literal no-brainer I mean someone
without a brain like myself knows this
rockauto.com is so much easier than
walking into a store and especially when
you're they're just gonna order the part
online anyway rockauto.com always offers
the lowest price as possible they're not
going to change the price they're not
gonna try to try to get as much as they
can out of you like like happens in so
many industries rockauto.com is a family
business they've been doing this for a
long time for 20 years but they're also
online you go to rockauto.com to shop
for auto embody parts from hundreds of
men
factures whatever you're looking for I
guarantee you they're gonna have it best
of all prices rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the selection is always
reliably expensive the rockauto.com
catalog is unique easy to navigate
quickly see the parts you're looking for
and then make your decision make your
purchase go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
truck right Walsh in there how did you
hear about this box so that they know
that we sent you okay for our daily
cancelation it's a little bit different
I'm gonna be cancelling all of the
celebrities in the white-guilt celeb PSA
that I'm gonna play for you just a
second but I'm not gonna spend time
explaining why they're cancelled and why
it's dumb and all of that that should be
pretty obvious and the incredible thing
is that with these celebrity videos
these celebrity videos are roundly
mocked by almost everyone on all sides
every time they are always a huge fail
and yet the celebs keep doing it they
keep doing it they must know at this
point that it's just gonna be made fun
of by everybody not just not just
conservatives everyone in fact I started
the show talking about there's nothing
that binds us together in unites us this
might be the one thing left is that we
all hate celebrity PSAs this is the one
thing holding us together which means
probably they should keep doing it this
is the only thing stopping us from a
full-on Civil War is that at least we
have this in common now what I really
like to do then is is a little game a
little challenge I came up with called
the cringe challenge the game is to
watch this video for as long as you can
until the cringe factor is overwhelming
and you have to stop it for fear that
you might die of second-hand secondhand
embarrassment now I warn you this is not
for the faint of heart if you've seen
any celebs in the past you know how
cringy they get this one is way worse
okay this is this is the ultimate right
here this is expert level cringe
challenge so if you've never played the
cringe challenge we're going to be
jumping into the deep end with
this it's a dangerous maneuver but I
think now is the time to do it so we're
gonna watch it together
I'll see how far I can go and one note
about the rules okay you you can try
multiple times to see how far you can
make it but if you have to stop then
then you have to go back to the
beginning and do it all from the
beginning again those are the rules
sorry I don't make them up actually I do
make them up but still those are the
rules all right so let's let me pull the
video up okay we're gonna watch this
together
it's 206 the video is a little bit over
two minutes can we get through the
entire video let's see all right I take
responsibility I take responsibility
hi 18 okay I got a I got stuff I got to
stop already that Aaron Paul the pause
there the pause with the with the hands
like this oh man the pause did me in I
couldn't even was that four seconds five
seconds and that's Aaron that's Jesse
Pinkman it kills me kills me that Jesse
Pinkman is being corny right now
why did Jesse pin you and II - Jesse
Pinkman okay we're gonna try again hmm
let's give this another shot all right
let's go
sponsibility I take responsibility I
take responsibility I take
responsibility for every unchecked
moment for every time it was easier to
ignore than to call it up for what it
was
every not so funny joke no stop stop
stop I can't do it
every not so funny joke oh man that guy
who is that guy is that who is that I
don't even know who these people are
I can't even rec I don't know who these
Jesse Pinkman I recognized is that is
that that Justin Theroux is that who
that is I don't know
anyway he
whoo that's a tough one that's a tight
he he he's really he's got the finishing
move doesn't he was that 20 seconds he's
coming in I mean that's that's that's a
hard one get past okay let's try again
I'll try one more time I know I can do
better than this I you know I've been
watching cringe comedy like the office a
lot of British comedy Ricky Gervais is
now I've been watching cringe comedy my
whole life I I thought that this would
prepare me for this moment but it turns
out that it's it's it's different at
game speed when you're actually doing it
in real life it's a lot harder so
alright let's try again I take
responsibility I take responsibility I
take responsibility I take
responsibility for every unchecked
moment for every time it was easier to
ignore than to call it out for what it
was every not so funny joke every unfair
stereotype every blatant injustice no
matter how big or small every time I
remained silent
every time I explained away police
brutality or turned a blind eye no no no
I'm done I can't do it the pause is it's
it's the dramatic pauses that are that's
that's the cringy estamos not even it's
not what there's it is what they're
saying I mean it's everything everything
about this the music the black-and-white
the everything those dramatic theatrical
pauses they keep taking oh yeah that's
at 36 seconds I'm a failure I can't do
it
that's that's is that's that's the best
I could do I kind of want to literally
just keep playing a little bit I'm not
gonna break my own rules because I can
break my own rules I'm gonna play a
little bit more of this just to the
game's over I already lost but I want to
see what else I do want to see who is
this right here that we're looking at I
don't know but I want to see what she
has to say well we'll just go a little
bit further into this I take
responsibility
black people are being slaughtered in
the streets killed in their own homes
these are our brothers and sisters our
friends our family we are done watching
them die we are no longer bystanders we
will not be idle enough is enough I will
no longer allow an unchecked moment I
will no longer allow racist hurtful
words jokes stereotypes no matter how
big or small to be uttered in my
presence
okay all right that's it we're good
we're fine I've done it I'm to be
uttered we're no longer allowed to be
uttered in my presence
why do you say like that and I think
it's they're reading you could tell
they're reading a script they could even
memorize their lines I will no longer
allow racism to be uttered it won't be
uttered No all right that's it that's it
that's the most I could do that I told
you that's a tough one but that's too if
you want to go on your own try it it's
it's if you want to play this game at
home on your own and see if you can get
all through all two minutes let me know
if you could do it I want to move on to
emails haven't read emails in a while
and we're gonna do that in just a second
but first you know the daily wire reader
pass we've been telling you about 99
cents right now to get a reader pass if
you do it right now because there's so
much going on in the news and if you
want to get that in-depth analysis from
the daily wire cut through all the
liberal BS then you need to get a reader
pass now the membership tier is already
a bargain at $3 a month but if you join
today you get your first month for 99
cents you also get access to our mobile
app and receive push notifications for
breaking news and special content as
well as you join the community of daily
our members who are actively commenting
and discussing our content with each
other that's mobile ad free access to
all the daily wire news exclusive op-eds
and more on our date on our mobile app
all for the low price of one dollar best
of all your dollars are getting you the
news you need without the left to spin
so go to daily wire comm slash subscribe
right now and begin okay we haven't done
a lot of emails in a while so I want to
I want to read a couple of them you can
email the show but coming a daily wire
member as well that will give you access
to the mailbag and this is from Ron says
Matt first I would like to let you know
how much I enjoy your show your common
sense approaches refreshing on today's
show you mentioned the Gulag Archipelago
with Solzhenitsyn's magnum opus and then
said he had many great opuses oppai
maybe as the plural that I just about
fell out laughing I live in Japan and
oppai is the Japanese word for breast
specifically female breasts so what went
through what went through my mind was he
had many great
oppai I just thought it was funny and
that you may appreciate the humor well
Ron no I don't appreciate the humor at
all
I knew that oppai was the word for
female breasts in Japanese I am fluent
in Japanese okay but this was a test I
was testing you to see how enlightened
and tolerant you are and sir you failed
miserably there should be nothing funny
to you about a man like Solzhenitsyn
having many great female breasts why is
that funny well say soldier
and had two female breasts maybe he had
three maybe had one maybe had seven and
a half it's up to him okay
this is his life it's his choice his
truth if he wants to have seven and a
half female breasts on his body who are
you to say you can't the fact that you
would laugh at something like that is
shocking outrageous and I find your
cruelty to be traumatizing for me I can
only imagine how Solzhenitsyn must feel
even though he's dead just makes it even
worse insult to injury so we still have
far to come as a society is my point so
we'll move on to the next email it says
from manda says hi Matt I enjoy your
show that said I think you're off on
your take on the statue issue you
glossed over it during your segment but
the fact remains that Columbus enslaved
women and children he was a murderer and
a slave owner and trader
I don't see why trader as in trad er
said I don't see why a man like that
needs to have a statue and the
Confederates do you really think it
makes sense to have statues of traders
on American trader as in tra itor okay
this isn't good look a fusing do you
think it makes sense to have statues of
traders on American soil traders and
traders is what we got I guess Amanda
you know I think I already addressed
many of your points in you know over the
last few days I've addressed a lot of
this in the case of Columbus yes I think
he deserves the statue being one of the
most significant men in history one of
the greatest men in the history of the
world you know a little detail like that
like being one of the great men in
history I think that is deserving of a
statue or two did he engage in slavery
and other atrocities yes he did was that
bad yes it was can we assess his moral
culpability for those actions through
our 21st century lens and hold him to a
modern standard on those issues no we
certainly cannot we cannot do that you
know you have to understand a man of 500
years ago is a long time it's a very
very long time I know that might seem
obvious but I apparently for a lot of
people like
you its it you know it's not so obvious
very it's half a millennium ago the
world back then was nothing like what it
is now it may as well have been an alien
planet in outer space somewhere in terms
of how different it was from our
experience in modern times it was a
brutal violent age across the world
concepts like the absolute equality of
the races didn't exist nobody believed
in that I mean not a single person who
existed in 1492 would pass as racially
enlightened and woke by our standards
today not a single person and you know
all of the great men everywhere in all
parts of the world were by necessity
hard-bitten violent tough cruel you know
we could shake our heads about that now
but we do it from the comfort of our
modern life enjoying the fruits of the
labor done by those men we have the
benefit the luxury the privilege to be
scandalized by the brutality of older
times they didn't have that privilege
you know for them it was reality that
doesn't excuse anything we're talking
we're not talking about moral truth
we're talking about moral culpability
I'm not saying that slavery was morally
okay back then just because ever most
people thought it was I'm saying the
moral culpability moral culpability of
someone you know someone who owns slaves
if if your neighbor Jim was found to
have been owning slaves that he had tied
up in his basement or something he would
be much more morally culpable for his
slave ownership than a person 500 years
ago would be and I think that's just
undeniable it's I mean any thinking
person must realize this and so I you
know we have to judge everyone through
that lens Columbus included now one
other point though a different point
you're arguing that these statues
shouldn't exist that's what you're
arguing you're saying that they
shouldn't have the statute that is
that's different there's a distinction
or that's different from arguing that
they should be porn down so maybe you
see
a difference I would say statues are all
about symbolism tearing a statue down is
symbolism there's there's there's
symbolism in that especially when an
angry mob tears it down illegally it's a
lot of symbolism in that what I would
say is that the symbolism of tearing
down a historical statue particularly
when it's a mob doing it is terrible
awful and so for that reason I think you
know a reasonable person could be of the
opinion that a particular statue isn't
great and they don't love it and they
wish that it was never put up but they
are not in favor of it being torn down I
think that's a position a person could
take that's not my position when it
comes to Columbus I like the statues and
think they should be up if it were up to
me I'd put them up but there's there's
just it's like it's it's one thing if
you know you're part of a community and
they're talking about putting a statue
up that isn't up yet and you don't like
the statue and so you're saying no don't
put that statue that's a very different
argument from saying this statue has
been up for a hundred years let's tear
it down
especially when it's part of a of a
hysterical rush a panic to tear down
statues all across the country these are
not isolated incident this is happening
all across the country and what is the
symbolism in tearing all these statues
down all at once across the country at
the behest of the mob the symbolism is
is one of affirming mob rule it's one of
of you know condemning completely our
our historical what we were once our
historical heroes you know when you tear
down Columbus statues all over the place
the message you're sending is not that
okay we need to have a more nuanced view
of Columbus I mean there were a lot of
bad things that he did we need to we
need to also be talking about that
that's not the message the message is
this was a scum he was dirt he's nothing
we shouldn't even remember him that's
the message you send when you tear him
down all across the country that's a
terrible message to send
if we want to have a more nuanced
perspective on the the people who
pioneered and founded and shaped Western
civilization and later on the United
States of America I'm all about that
Thomas Jefferson George Washington you
want to talk about the slavery issue in
relation to them they were slave owners
yeah I'm fine with that these were not
perfect men they weren't Saints I don't
think any church anywhere is canonizing
these people so I'm fine with that but
tearing down the statues is not what you
do in order to begin a nuanced
conversation that's what you do when you
are condemning totally these people and
throwing them on the ash heap and that I
oppose absolutely Poe's we can't do that
all right we will a couple other here
others here but I'm long-winded as usual
so we'll have to save those for later
and hope you guys have a great weekend
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling our technical
producer is Austin Stephens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune into the Ben Shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there